there's a clip that's gone viral I have
intentionally tried not to follow the
details of this too much because the
whole story is just absolute tabloid
trash and I don't want to Sully my mind
or Soul following too closely what's
going on but the the broad Strokes of it
are that some Tick Tock chick
had an affair with a rock star with the
singer from Maroon 5 who's married and
has kids and now she's making tick tocks
to get more attention talking about how
she had this affair
I was I'm interfer with a man who's
married to a Victoria's Secret model at
the time you know I was
young I was naive and I mean quite
frankly I feel exploited I wasn't in the
scene like I am now
um so I was definitely very easily
manipulated
Maroon 5 is practically elevator music
at this point so I'm sure you know who
Adam Levine is
um but Adam and I were seeing each other
for about a year
after I stopped talking to him over you
know a period of months this is uh how
he came back into my life
he said okay serious question I'm having
another baby and if it's a boy I really
uh want to name it Sumner you okay with
that dead serious
um
I was like
I'm in hell like I have to be in hell at
this point I mean my morals were
unknowingly compromised I was completely
manipulated
she was totally manipulated she's such a
victim she uh knowingly and willingly
had a year-long affair with a married
man a married man with multiple children
but she's just such a victim you know
don't you think she's such a victim
I don't actually I actually think she
should just sort of shut up and be quiet
about it
and apologize to the man's wife and
and stop pretending that this is all
about her the only victims here are this
man's wife and children those are the
victims okay and the man and the woman
did something very bad and I'm not just
here to shame them and and
moralize and
wag my finger okay Drew Clavin has a
great point he says that every man has
two drinks and a wink away from ruining
his life okay I I have a great Terror
I'm very glad that I haven't done this I
hope I never do this I have a great
Terror of I mean this is probably the
thing I fear the most could you imagine
betraying the people who you love the
most who are so close to you it's awful
there before the grace of God goes all
of us
but
if they do this terrible thing
apologize and and try to atone and keep
it to yourself but we can't do that in
our culture anymore anymore because the
only thing that we can do in our culture
is is claim to be the victim everything
has to be about us everything has to be
about seeking attention and somehow
everything is everyone else's fault
except for our own this is just the flip
side of that same Pride that Pride that
says I know everything and I'm such a
genius and you know I went I got three
degrees at Harvard and that's why little
boys are actually little girls and we
should chop off their genitals because
I'm so smart and these people look like
idiots the flip side of that is never
feeling any sense of shame or guilt if
you do because you can't do anything
wrong because you're so smart and great
right you you have to be the victim even
at the time you didn't think of yourself
as the victim even as you're explaining
it it's so implausible that you would be
the victim but you have to be the victim
because you're so you're perfect right
this girl in her mind she's just
absolutely perfect she can't do anything
wrong
that's the flip side of it too it's just
that I mean it makes sense sometimes we
talk about slavery is America's original
sin I don't think that's America's
original sin original sin is America's
original sin and pride which causes the
fall the queen of all vices that is just
absolute poison you see it in it
virtually every aspect of social
corruption
now
what one wants to do if one wants to
avoid these sorts of terrible things and
destroying one's life and family I would
be to stay focused and some people can't
really stay focused speaking of focus
Joe Biden insists
that he is mentally very very focused
some people think that he's in decline
in senility and and you know gets lost
when a butterfly flies in front of his
face but no he says he is very very
focused just listen to him how would you
say your mental focus is
oh it's focused
I say it's I think it's I I haven't look
I have trouble even mentioning even
saying to myself my own head the number
of years I know more think of myself as
being as old as I am than fly
I mean it's just not uh
I haven't observed anything in terms of
there's not things I don't do now that I
did before whether it's physical or
mental or anything else
that's the polished edited version
that's the best version that 60 Minutes
could present of Joe Biden people say
people say I'm Sam and you can even say
it's kind of sad you can see it in how
vacant Joe Biden's eyes are he's kind of
got that that look to him that people
who are in sinality have and he said
people say I'm and I'm not and I'm folk
and I'm focused I could fly you know and
there are things that I
and I don't do things that I did that I
do things I never I don't there's
nothing I didn't do that I do
you know you know the thing really
really sad obviously
obviously not all with it this is why
the Democrats are all circling the
wagons to try to give themselves
positions
I was talking to Ted Cruz about this uh
last night
he said you know he sees this pretty
pretty up close and personal in DC
he said you could tell for six months
now Buddha judge and Kamala both want to
replace Biden when he obviously can't
run for president in 2024. and they're
already starting to stab each other in
the back and go on TV as much as
possible
they're already trying to do it and when
you look at the dysfunction
of our system
it's it's tempting right now to look
around the world and say is there any
better sort of system and this is an
especially a good time for that because
of the death of Queen Elizabeth
there's a ton of focus on the British
form of government specifically on the
monarchical aspect of the British form
of government and all these rituals and
there are some people in America
and in Great Britain but especially in
America who are making fun of all the
rituals who think this is why on Earth
is some random family just given all
this money and all this Prestige and
they're looked up to and all this Pomp
and Circumstance and the guys wearing
the funny tall hats standing guard
around it's just like totally crazy we
would never do that kind of crazy thing
in America you saw there were these
beautiful ceremonies before Queen
Elizabeth was laid to rest yesterday
there were these wonderful vigils where
her son the king
and his siblings would stand vigil
around the casket not like someone was
going to come vandalize it anyway and
not like Prince Charles now King Charles
was going to do anything about it in
particular but they just stand there and
there's a ritual and this ritual has
gone on for hundreds and hundreds of
years the Americans look at that
especially the liberal kind of Americans
they say who needs all that stupid
ritual
what they don't realize is that we have
it too I was thinking back to Ruth Bader
ginsburg's lying in state Ruth Bader
Ginsburg lies in state
and where was it was it in the U.S
Capitol I don't know some you know big
fancy government building in DC and
she's there and the the coffin is draped
in the American flag and there are
people standing vigil and standing guard
and then at one point as people are
coming to pay their respects to the
coffin ginsburg's personal trainer walks
up and starts doing push-ups in front of
the coffin as a kind of Final Act of
loyalty and respect to Ruth Bader
Ginsburg and this happened for days and
days and days we're doing the exact same
thing that the British do with their
monarchy the only difference is that
we're doing it in a less dignified way
for people who are much less deserving
of it
the queen gave her entire life to
service of the crown and suppressed her
own desires and interests all along the
way and suffered all sorts of
indignities and yes she had a palace and
yes she had servants and yes she had a
bunch of money but money actually
doesn't buy happiness she didn't have
the freedom of choice to do pretty much
anything she wanted her whole life was
about Duty and she did it in a very
dignified way because she recognized
that there are obligations in society
and traditions that must be maintained
and she she remained that symbol of
unity for Great Britain and a period of
massive social upheaval when a lots of
other societies did not fare nearly as
well as Britain did
and she did it and now people are paying
formal respect to her as they lay her to
rest we do all that same stuff here in
America we just pretend that we don't
and it's all kind of weird and kooky and
it's for people who are not deserving of
one one thousandth this sort of respect
that Queen Elizabeth was because you
can't escape this stuff much as we want
to pretend that we're sort of radical
modernist rationalists Republican people
who are all done with the crazy myths
and Pomp and Circumstance of of the old
monarchies were not because man is an
incarnate being and an essentially
religious being and we're liturgical and
we're ritualistic and we need all of
these sorts of things and we must have
in society things that are held sacred
and we must have shared religious and
moral beliefs and we much must have a
shared standards and when we get rid of
the old ones the good ideas of virtue
and Duty and Christianity when we get
rid of all of that it's not like we just
are left with nothing and it's an it's
an empty vacuum what we what comes in is
a bunch of insane new ideas to fill that
space like transgenderism and a kind of
cult of personal autonomy and abortion
happy robed lawyers
that are treated in the same way as a
British monarch
it's absolutely it's undeniable and so
the question is not how do we get rid of
all these crazy old rituals the question
is what should the rituals be what do
what do we Revere what do we venerate
what do we hold sacred
I'm so glad you like that clip now hold
up you gotta ring that Bell subscribe
get all the notifications we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]